the hype behind Haunted Mansion was
pretty convincing before it flopped at
the box office is it actually bad or is
there more to the story
a haunted mansion film should in theory
be the perfect cinematic outing for any
family eager to occupy their time for
two hours Disney previously adapted
Haunted Mansion with Eddie Murphy back
in 2003 while Murphy's co-lab with
Disney was a critical misfire it was a
mild success at the box office proving
that it wasn't IP worth revisiting with
the 2023 film Disney and director Justin
Simeon had the opportunity to learn from
the 2003 films missteps noticeably they
could have paid attention to how the
Murphy film attempted to be both a
comedy and horror project but failed to
succeed on either front history clearly
repeats itself as contemporary audiences
had the same issues the 2023 film Looper
critics Cynthia Vinnie was mixed on the
reboot criticizing it for having a
lackluster plot and not doubling down on
either horror or comedy several critics
agree with the sentiment calling the
film out for a genre inconsistencies
playing audience members also felt the
same way giving the film a b-plus cinema
score which is a pretty decent grade
generally speaking but not for what
should have been a crowd-pleasing flick
the film failed to engage audience says
in any kind of meaningful way which led
to poor Word of Mouth naturally the film
created in its sophomore weekend
suffering a 62 drop with a 9 million
dollar gross
filmmakers have always Blended horror
and comedy together to create Timeless
projects the fusion of the genres has
resulted in some of the greatest films
of all time like Ghostbusters and
Beetlejuice
you two kids pick me you didn't have to
but you pick me it makes me want to kiss
you guys come on no the blend equally
works well with children's films with
projects like 2015's Goosebumps and Eli
Ross the house with a clock in its walls
proving to be both Financial successes
and favorites amongst children why did
the 2023 Haunted Mansion stumble despite
being a key part of the world's most
recognizable brand it simply didn't
appeal to audiences while initial
reactions to the Haunted Mansion
trailers were positive especially
amongst fans of the ride Disney wasn't
able to sustain positive momentum thanks
in prior to the sag-aftra strike the
ongoing strike prohibits actors from
promoting their films in any in all
capacity and unfortunately the Haunted
Mansion its release coincided with the
strike restricting stars like lucky
Stanfield and Rosario Dawson from
discussing the film at press junkets or
untalk shows limiting the Project's
ability to break out with little to no
promotion Haunted Mansion was said to be
a disappointment with no stars to rely
on director Justin Simeon was thrust
into the position of promoting the film
solo while speaking with The Hollywood
Reporter Simeon expressed that no
promotion from its leading Stars would
have a pretty dramatic impact on the
film Simeon told the publication it's
not a sequel to that first movie or a
remake it's not building on an existing
audience we need publicity we need Word
of Mouth this is going to hurt it
it makes sense why Disney decided to
release Haunted Mansion during the
middle of the summer kids are out of
school which means families are
incentivized to kill time at the cinemas
while the box office hasn't fully
recovered from the covid-19 pandemic
families are showing up to Cinemas and
droves with several of the year's
biggest hits being kid-centric and
family friendly projects so far the
highest grossing film of the year is the
Super Mario Brothers movie with a
domestic gross of 574 million dollars
other noteworthy hits include the
animated Spider-Man across the
spider-verse and Disney's A Little
Mermaid clearly families and children
are enjoying their return back to the
cinemas you can't live in that world
unless
you become a human yourself birds with
so much competition at the multiplex it
was difficult for Haunted Mansion to
break out so thanks was misguided July
28 release the film opened at number
three just behind the juggernauts Barbie
and Oppenheimer World Haunted Mansion
isn't in competition with the R-rated
Oppenheimer it did likely face some
Strife from Barbie which has grossed
over 1 billion dollars worldwide both
Barbie and Haunted Mansion are PG-13 and
appeal to families and teenagers seeing
as Barbie was able to promote itself
prior to the SAG after a strike and was
a recipient of thousands of memes it
stands to reason that the film was far
more appealing to audiences beyond that
Haunted Mansion released during a month
where there were far more Superior
horror films for viewers to visit the
film's debut coincided with the release
of a24's talk to me which opens to 10
million dollars in his second weekend
Haunted Mansion was eclipsed by the
family-friendly teenage mutant ninja
turtles mutant Mayhem a film that has
already outgrowth the spooky Disney
flick this place it's haunted
even with a more promising release dates
and promotions from its leading Stars
there's still a chance that Haunted
Mansion would have bombed at the box
office despite mixed reviews the film
could have genuinely succeeded if not
for his bloated budget it's somewhat
mind-boggling to see that Haunted
Mansion boasts a budget of 150 million
dollars budgets are soar north of 100
million dollars are typically reserved
for large-scale Action Blockbusters such
as superhero fair or projects that
already have a built-in brand while
Haunted Mansion is definitely an IP play
for Disney it also doesn't have the same
cultural weight and finesse as our other
multimedia Brands like Star Wars or
Marvel I can show you what happened but
it will cost you for a film with a
budget of 150 million dollars Haunted
Mansion would need to make a significant
chunk of change to be considered
profitable and unlike the Pirates of the
Caribbean series which has widespread
appeal as an action-adventure franchise
Haunted Mansion is bogged down because
of its horror genre only one horror film
this year Scream 6 has grossed over 100
million dollars domestically meaning
that the genre still has its limits in
terms of potential sure Mansion isn't a
pure horror film and has comedic
elements but it's clearly being dragged
down by its subject matter
foreign